you'd have to be a lily-livered no-good
two-time and dog-faced pony soldier to
even
begin to suggest that joe biden is in a
state
of cognitive decline well biden did an
interview just the other day with yahoo
news
so this is not exactly a right wing
outlet but
the journalist raised the question is
joe biden taking
cognitive tests is he in cognitive
decline
and joe biden kind of proved the point
of the question
have you taken a cognitive no i haven't
taken the test
why the hell would i take a test come on
man
that's like saying you before you got in
this program you take a test where
you're taking
cocaine or not what do you think huh are
you
what do you say to president trump
who brags about his test and makes your
mental state
an issue for voters well
if he can't figure out the difference
between an elephant and a lion
i don't know what the hell he's talking
about did you watch that look come on
man
i i know you're trying to goad me but i
mean
i'm so forward looking to have an
opportunity
to sit with the president or stand with
the president and debates
there can be plenty of time and by the
way as i joke with them you know
i i shouldn't say it i'm going to say
something i don't i i probably shouldn't
say
anyway i am uh i am very
willing to let the american public judge
my physical mental
my physical as well as my mental fitness
come on man come on you think that guy
might
might be missing a step or two might be
a couple
couple bulbs short of a pack might be uh
a couple fries short of a happy meal i
don't know i'm using a lot of i'm using
a lot of metaphors here
the point is joe biden's obviously in
mental decline okay and
you don't need to take my word for it
and you don't need to take the
suggestions of the journalists or or the
president for that matter
because joe biden actually told us
months ago that he does regularly take
cognitive tests have you been tested for
some degree of cognitive decline
i've been tested and i'm constantly
testing look
all you all i got to do is watch me and
i can hardly
wait to compare my cognitive capability
to the cognitive capability of the man
i'm running against
in joe's defense it seems pretty clear
that he forgot what he said just a
couple months ago right you just chalk
it up
chalk it up to forgetfulness joe biden's
forgetting his own
mental decline come on man forgetfulness
is the whole strategy here the democrats
want you to forget not just what joe
biden said a few months ago what joe
biden has been saying and doing for his
whole career
the whole premise of joe biden winning
leading in the polls rather
winning right now if the election were
held today according to the pollsters is
that nobody's seen or heard from joe
biden
beyond a one or two minute snippet for
six months
we'll remind them i'm michael knowles
this the michael knowles show
[Music]
come on man i'm forward looking to this
episode
i can't wait to exhibit my own cognitive
powers in this episode and i don't want
to forget things i want to remind people
of what joe biden is not just right now
what he's been for his whole career
first though
got to point out my favorite comment on
the youtubes yesterday this is from
mct fly referring to democratic senator
hirono
who stormed out of that that meeting
yesterday
where or two days ago rather when
senator cruz
was grilling her on whether or not she
could condemn antifa
said hirono is such a great example of
masking one's
ignorance with arrogance that's a great
observation you actually just saw
joe biden do that in the previous clip
you see him the moment he's called out
and says
joe you don't seem like you're too with
it these days you seem like you don't
know a whole lot of stuff and you're a
little bit slow
what does he do he starts laughing at
the guy derisively starts mocking him
calls him a junkie for some reason then
talks about the difference between an
elephant and a lion and it goes
obviously goes downhill from there but
what he's pushing forward is this
arrogance
joe biden famously did this in the vice
presidential debate when he was running
against romney ryan when he was when he
was debating
paul ryan there ryan would make
generally good points
and then joe biden would just laugh in
his face and you see a lot of people do
this especially just in the pop culture
what they'll do
is they'll they'll say you know left
wingers who confront their first
conservative
and a conservative says you know i think
maybe men aren't women or you know i
think babies might
actually be babies or you know i think
george washington was kind of good
or whatever you know stating basic facts
and the left rather than engage will
usually just laugh at them scoff at them
say oh you idiot
you rube you don't know science you
don't you're
you're not educated you're a bitter
clinger you're a deplorable irredeemable
but that that is an
arrogance that is masking one's own
ignorance
and it doesn't play very well even among
what that group we've called for the
past few days the silenced
majority of americans there's a
representative
i think of that that big group in the
middle who is really souring on joe
we'll get to that in one second first
i've got to thank our friends
over at lifelock you know a criminal
scheme
involving nearly 50 000 falsified
unemployment insurance claims
has been discovered by maryland state
officials this scam
adds up to more than 500 million dollars
in claims
while it is capitalizing upon the
hardships caused by kovit the fraud
involved in identity theft
from previous security breaches is only
mounting maryland isn't alone
other states are experiencing similar
unemployment fraud
every day we put a ton of our
information on the internet right
no matter what you're doing your phone
on your computer we put all that
information out there
you could miss certain identity threats
by just monitoring your credit
good thing there is lifelock now no one
can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions at all
businesses
but i trust these guys i rely on these
guys lifelock can see threats that you
might miss on your own
right now join up save up to 25
off your first year it's a great
discount at a good time
especially when we're spending a lot
more time even than usual on the
internet go to lifelock.com
knowles canada wlas that is a lifelock
dot com slash knowles kenner wles for
25 off
we're not the only ones noting joe's
mental decline
it started out it was conservatives
pointing this out president trump
pointing this out now even mainstream
journalists are starting to bring it up
like this yahoo news guy and then joe
rogan the most prominent podcaster on
planet earth
no right winger by any means he was a
bernie bro during the primaries
joe rogan says it's pretty clear at this
point that biden is declining
and more importantly than that there's a
lot of voters in this country who maybe
they don't love trump maybe they're not
rock ribbed republicans maybe
maybe they don't have much of a
political view at all
they're just not comfortable with a guy
who can't pronounce
basic words or string together an
english sentence
running the most powerful office in the
world
i believe there's an also large group of
people that are very uncomfortable with
a man who seems to be mentally
compromised winning the election
and doing so by hiding i mean the guys
never
he was just at another thing the other
day and he forgot where he was yeah
and that happens all the time he forgets
where he is all the time and he forgot
his own name
he forgot the name of god and the
declaration of independence
he forgets a lot the democratic party
though
is capitalizing on this they're relying
on this
it's it's not breaking news that joe
biden has has lost a few steps
but what i think people are not fully
appreciating here
is that forgetfulness is the name of the
game this is how the democratic party
and the liberal establishment memory
whole stories that they just want you to
forget about they've been doing it for
decades
right what they would do the clintons
were most famous for this there would be
a scandal
and they would deny deny deny deny deny
and then finally when they couldn't deny
it anymore they'd say well that's old
news
oh forget about that who cares and then
they'd bury it the media would bury it
you know nothing would be taught in
history books we just forget about these
things
that's what the the left has relied on
for a long time that's why
the left rewrites history is trying to
erase historical figures
and in the case of joe biden they're
hiding him in a basement right he is
very rarely leaving
his home every time he does any kind of
media hit
there's some complete embarrassment
where he's defending his own
his own cognitive strength by
contradicting himself from a couple
months ago
and then not being able to finish the
phrase mental fitness
so they've got to hide him joe biden's
poll numbers right now if you trust the
polls
are pretty good they're good because
people don't remember
what and who joe biden is that's
something that the people have in common
with joe biden himself
they don't remember who this guy is
every time they see him
his numbers go down which is not a good
sign for a candidate
it means that as the race gets hotter if
there are debates
joe's numbers are going to continue to
decline now what the democrats are
banking on
is that joe's got such a lead right now
depending on which poll you look at he's
got a pretty substantial lead
that it will decline slow enough that
joe biden perhaps himself might decline
slow enough to get him over the finish
line
for november and they're trying to do
everything they can to preserve that by
keeping the country shut down
keeping the economy shut down canceling
the conventions and even trying to
cancel
the debates so what is joe biden's
strategy
he's in a little bit of a pickle because
you can't
when you're running for president you do
have to have a message to people so what
they're doing is they're relying on
highly produced
television ads joe biden's campaign just
announced on wednesday that they've made
the single largest ad buy
in presidential campaign history ever
you know they've got a fair bit of money
on hand and they're not going to have to
spend it on events
they're not going to have to spend it
traveling around the country they don't
intend to travel anywhere
so they're putting what is an estimated
220 million dollars
into tv spots then on top of that
60 million into digital and social media
advertising
probably the biden campaign should have
evened that out a little bit more
in both political parties but especially
the dems they don't understand
that internet marketing matters much
much more now digital marketing matters
much much more than tv
but in any case they're going to try to
mobilize older voters
and i i suspect what they're going to do
is try to mobilize people who might have
called themselves moderate republicans
who are much older i think many people
have
have family members like this who are
who are just so put off by trump's
brashness
that they are willing to vote for
someone like joe biden especially
because joe biden is around their same
age and they've known him for about 50
50 years so that's a lot of money
and a lot of these ads are not going to
be 30 second ads are going to be 60
second ad so it'll just be joe biden
in this perfectly manicured way for the
the entire ad break in some cases
the biden campaign signaled they were
going to do this when they launched that
podcast that no one listens to but when
you listen to the podcast you realize
which us professionals did have to do
uh you you see that they would
reduce the spaces in between his words
they would speed up his language
they would obviously heavily edit out
and take out all the weird stuff that he
was saying in the meantime
so they're going to create this
computer-generated idea of a candidate
who really does not
have much bearing on joe biden himself
this is taking empty suit
to a new level this is taking just a
sort of empty vessel of the democratic
party
and that difference between the ideology
and the reality to a whole
new level so they still have this
problem which is that
donald trump gets earned media there's a
difference between paid media when you
buy ads
and earn media when the news covers you
trump can get earned media whenever he
wants
this has been true since the 80s and
it's especially true
now that he's president so the one thing
i would say is
republicans don't necessarily need to
spend dollar for dollar and squander all
their money on tv ads too
because trump is getting a lot more
earned media and biden has to rely on
the tv ads because he's not going out
anywhere so he's not getting
that earned media what the trump
campaign could focus on a lot more than
running a bunch of tv
ads is pointing out relentlessly
the reality of joe biden not the the
manicured
contrived thing of the of the 32 or 60
second tv ads
but the real joe biden and the real joe
biden right now is seriously considering
an
actual communist to be his running mate
an actual out and out communist i mean
she denies it but they all deny it
but karen bass the head of the
congressional black caucus
is a commie there's just no two ways
about it okay
this woman volunteered with a commie
group in the 70s
she was a partially a leader of that
group
to go down to fidel castro's cuba and
support the castro regime
even in the past few years she's spoken
very hot very highly of fidel castro
she's spoken very highly of marxist
organizations such as black lives matter
she is a close associate and supporter
of the founders of black lives matter
who are quote unquote trained marxists
when i confronted her about this on
television
she lied about it through her teeth
denied knowing these people
and now news just broke out that
karen bass just three years ago very
very recently
i gave a eulogy for the funeral of
o'neill
marion cannon don't know who that is
o'neil marian cannon was for
decades a leader of the communist party
usa
she not only gave this kami a eulogy but
she referred to him
as a friend and mentor which should not
surprise
anybody what the left is going to try to
do if karen bass continues
to to rise up in the possibility of
being or the probability of being a vp
pick
is they're going to say oh look her
radicalism that was in the 70s
that was 50 years ago for goodness sakes
forget about it
don't forget about it it wasn't 50 years
ago it was three years ago that she was
eulogizing
some of the biggest commie leaders in
the united states
and she is still supporting commie
organizations
trump i don't know if the trump campaign
has figured this out yet but i know that
president trump himself certainly has
trump has come out and stated this
problem explicitly he was asked
recently on fox and friends about black
lives matter
and he said without pulling any punches
black lives matter
is a marxist organization nobody's done
for the black community african-american
community
what i've done and i will tell you
they had black lives matter where did it
start
marching down streets screaming pigs in
a blanket
fry them like bacon they were talking
about policemen
policemen and women pigs in a blanket
fry them like bacon
so all of a sudden this has taken on
this air of
uh great respectability well
how does it start there it's a marxist
group
it's a marxist group that is not looking
for good things for our country and now
i see these leagues
all kneeling down and again nobody has
done more
for the black community by far i always
say nobody other than
i'll give the one exception abraham
lincoln okay
but even that i mean to be honest with
you but nobody
has done more than i have but when i see
people kneeling during the playing and
disrespecting our flag and disrespecting
our national anthem
what i do personally is turn off the
game
i love this this caveat okay maybe i'm
the best president for black people
maybe other than abraham lincoln
although frankly even him i don't know
okay moving on
and so i love that i mean obviously this
is entertaining stuff he's calling into
a top-rated morning show
people are listening to this but
crucially what he's doing here he's not
just
throwing attacks at his political
opponents or the blm movement which is
it's important that he's recognizing how
radical left
the blm movement is but he's reminding
people of history
history is the key here the
forgetfulness is the key here
the left hates history
that's why they want to rewrite history
and when they don't rewrite history they
want to erase history
and we're not they're not erasing
history books they're
desecrating and tearing down historical
statues historical figures
not even just the really bad ones you
know the ones who
sided with the confederacy or something
like that they're pulling down
george washington they're pulling down
thomas jefferson
because they have a narrative they have
this narrative that america was racist
and terrible from the beginning and it's
awful and
you no one should support it and we've
got to get away from that history and
overturn that history and
liberate ourselves from the oppressive
past then we can move forward into the
progressive future now anybody who
actually reads the founding fathers
anybody who looks into their lives will
find out that what the left is saying is
complete bs
the founding was not racist wasn't
racist at all
the institution of slavery existed
obviously that institution complicates
american history but to call the
founders and the founding racist
or bigoted or oppressive or whatever is
absurd it's not defensible if you know
the history
so what does the left do they want to
erase history and here's what trump does
in a very
very practical way trump is so good at
this
at painting pictures at creating images
in your minds that's why
when he was talking about the the other
candidates in 2016
he would create these images so he'd
talk about you talk about how little
marco is always sweating
right you know he used to go back that
little marco he's always sweating and he
always likes to drink water he's always
sweating
he thought why is he going after him for
perspiration well he's doing it to
create this image
of a of a young politician who's nervous
who's not confident
who maybe isn't so sure of what he's
saying
jeb bush he got low energy jeb he didn't
call him a moderate jab or squishy jab
or liberal jab no
low energy it creates such an image of
this guy who's just
he's just a little lethargic he's not
going to be able to take the fight
to washington all these kinds of images
would come up
crooked hillary it's an image of a crook
even the idea of something being crooked
it's not quite straight it's not quite
right
and that's what he's doing here he says
you remember blm he doesn't talk about
the origins of blm
at the meeting of patrice calors and
opal to medi
and alicia garza getting funded by the
open society foundation which is run by
george soros he's not talking that's
way too technical he says you remember
blm was founded they were marching down
the street
saying pigs in a blanket fry them like
bacon
does that happen we saw that video that
creates a hideous ugly image it's an
image that actually took place by the
way
when blm was founded so that's where our
mind goes
that's what we have to remind people of
we have to remind people
of not just joe biden though we should
bring up his words
and his sayings and his role in history
too but the whole history
of the left of the democratic party
because people don't remember especially
with this
24-hour forget 24 hour now 24 minute
news cycle things are changing so
fast people forget about this kind of
thing and it's very easy then
to rewrite the past to erase the past
and move forward
into these ridiculous leftist ideologies
the greatest example of this recently
the most preposterous oprah winfrey
oprah winfrey is very very terrible
she is a very bad force in america
she her views on religion are heretical
her views on politics
are outrageous and damaging her
her deification in the media is
nauseating
she's a horribly negative influence in
american culture
and oprah winfrey true to form comes out
and
weighing in on this question of race
that we all have to talk about every
four years
because democrats think they can win
some votes if they gin up racial
tensions
oprah winfrey playing her part in doing
just that
comes out and from atop her throne of
2.6 billion dollars
tells people that if you're white
you have privilege if you're black
you're oppressed if you're white no
matter how poor you are
you have privilege because there's a
caste system in america
and race can never be overcome here is
the billionaire world famous
oprah winfrey complaining about how
oppressed she is
there are white people who are not as
powerful as
the system of white people the caste
system that's been put in place
but they still no matter where they are
on the wrong or the ladder of success
they still have their whiteness
as white people we we even the poorest
of the poor
i feel still has a leg up
um and the leg up is what i was saying
you still have your whiteness that's
what that's what the term white
privilege is it means that whiteness
still gives you an
advantage no matter what
that's it how many books have been
written about this sold zillions of
copies that if you're white
you get so much privilege you get so
many advantages
you get i'm sure you get advantages in
schooling right you get advantages in
applying to college you get advantages
in hiring don't you you get it oh wait a
second you don't you get disadvantaged
you get it's exactly the opposite of
what she says we only have one
system of legal racial discrimination in
this country
it's called affirmative action and it
disadvantages
white people and asian people how asian
people got thrown into the mix i have no
idea
but unfortunately they through no fault
of their own
i don't think they were complicit in
were they complicit in american slavery
i don't think so but anyway they get
disadvantaged too
and actually people of other races
including black
hispanic they are privileged they are
advantaged in a system
of legal racial discrimination
that's the reality of it some
poor guy in appalachia is not more
privileged than oprah winfrey
because he's a little less tan it's
preposterous on its face
it's outrageous it's i i think it's
dishonest
because i don't think oprah winfrey is
so stupid to actually believe the
nonsense
that she's spouting so i think it's
disingen i'm gonna give her the benefit
of the doubt and say she's lying
because otherwise she's profoundly
stupid and ignorant and i don't think
that could be the case
i don't think she became a billionaire
queen of all media by accident
i think this is a cynical campaign that
is premised on you forgetting
everything that's actually around you
forgetting
not just your history but even the
present state
of the law it's so
corrosive and it's corrosive not not
just
that it's unfair to white and asian
applicants to college or to jobs or
anything like that
it's unfair to the people it privileges
too there's this line that the left
always talks about
they say until we have racial equality
nobody is free
right that actually inequality
disadvantages even the people who are
privileged
because we live in this unjust society
well that that's certainly the case here
because even if there are legal
privileges
to being black or latino when you're
applying to colleges or jobs
the very fact that we are now told that
we are now telling children
that they can't succeed because of the
color of their skin
that's an ugly thing that will hurt
their lives that will down is
about the most damaging thing you can
possibly tell a child
and it is being pushed by cynical
hucksters
trying to divide the american people to
get votes
so what do we have to do we have to
remind people
of what is actually going on and we have
to unite people and this is why trump
is making such a point about the
american flag that's why he's making
such a point about the national anthem
he's saying
we have to come together as one nation
we have to reject the left divvying us
all up
divvying us all up through lies we have
to come together as one nation
or we will cease to be a nation and then
everything that we love and cherish
about this country
will fall apart the other
thing here is what is being pushed on
black people by ideologues
who think they know what black people
want or
or want black people to want what they
want is actually not
according to public opinion polls what
black people themselves want in america
there's a new poll gallup released on
wednesday that found
81 percent of black people want police
spending
to remain the same or or
increase in their communities
now we're told by the elites and the
ideologues
that black people hate the police
they're being oppressed by the police
they want to defund the police
no more than four out of five black
people
according to gallup very respected
polling firm
actually a little bit left-wing polling
firm wants
the same or more funding for the cops
that number compares to 88 for white
americans 83 percent for hispanics
72 for asian americans
and the whole the whole u.s population
on average is 86
there is a big gap between what people
want
and what ideologues want people to want
you see this actually beyond the level
of race
you see this when it comes to the covid
lockdown
to the vaccination we've now been told
that
you're not allowed to use
hydroxychloroquine you can't treat
coronavirus that way even though many
doctors have had success with it and
we've had the drug for a long time
nancy pelosi wants us all to smoke pot
she thinks that's going to cure
coronavirus i don't know how that one's
going to work
but what we've all been told is you've
got to wait for a vaccine we get the
vaccine then finally
we can reopen the country this is like
the fifth version of how we're going to
reopen remember initially it was
slow the spread 15 days to slow the
spread flatten the curve we
succeeded wildly at doing all of that
and then for some reason what that was
four months ago at that point they keep
moving the goal posts now it's the
vaccine
well the health and human services
secretary alex azar
is very excited because he can now say
that it's it's looking very good
that we will have a vaccine by the
winter or possibly
even the fall but there's still a
problem well let me talk about vaccine
because this has just been the last two
weeks
we've seen under president trump's
leadership the most historic advances in
the development of vaccines we've ever
seen in human history
the united states now has six vaccines
that we've placed
major investments in four of them have
already reported out positive
phase one clinical trial results and two
of them are already in the advanced
final phase three studies others will
advance there soon it's really just
president trump has
marshaled the whole of the us government
in our biopharmaceutical industry
on time fall is that a realistic
forecast for a vaccine available to the
public
it is very credible that we will have
the high tens of millions of doses of
fda gold standard
vaccine by the end of this year and many
hundreds of millions of doses of vaccine
by the beginning of next year
so it's good news by the end of this
year we're gonna have a lot of vaccines
and by the beginning of next year we'll
have even more
of the vaccines there's a problem though
which is that most people aren't going
to get it
i'm not i'm not saying that as a
prescriptive sort of thing as i'm not
saying
most people shouldn't get the vaccine
i'm just saying most people won't
there's a poll out it was just
undertaken by yahoo news and yougov
showed that only 42 percent of american
adults
say they will get the coronavirus
vaccine
now that number is actually down because
back in early may when this
poll asked the same question 55
said they would agree to be vaccinated
that's a big drop
in just a couple months it's a drop of
13 percentage points
what happened what happened is our
public health experts
got things wrong and they lied
and sometimes you know sometimes it's
accidental that they got things wrong
sometimes it seemed a little more
cynical than that but we
cannot trust them because they've been
wrong about this virus every step of the
way
and worse than that in their political
recommendations
they have lied to us and they've twisted
science for their political end so
they've said you can go out and protest
for blm and loot and riot and tear down
the country
and that's good the virus won't spread
that way and by the way we won't even
contact ratio if you go to one of those
protests so go out there and burn down
the country all in the name of science
but if you go and and say you want to go
to church on sunday
all of a sudden that's a felony you know
that's a crime you could be arrested for
doing that
all in the name of science all in the
name of public health it's bs so i'm not
surprised
the only people who bear blame
for for a majority of americans not
wanting to get vaccinated here
are the public health officials because
they've given us no reason to trust them
and and what the left will say is well
it's it's the republicans fault
it's the conservative's fault that they
won't get vaccinated first of all that's
not true
opposition to vaccines cuts across party
lines if anything it's more of a
left-wing phenomenon
than a right-wing phenomenon but also
if your political strategy cannot
accommodate
real people living real lives
if your political strategy only exists
in this abstract
ideological cloud then it's not much of
a political strategy at all
true socialism has never been tried true
social distances never been tried
before we get to the mailbag i do have
to get to one story
we've been talking about how we
shouldn't forget things for much of the
show
i'd like to give one example at least
where
it might be worth forgetting things
where we're remembering a little bit too
much this is the downside of big tech
and cancel culture
there's a woman maddie ziegler i had no
idea who this person was
until i read this news story maddie
ziegler is a dancer and an actress
she is currently 17 years old
and she's issued a public apology for
offensive comments and jokes that she
made in the past
how far in the past could that be she's
17 years old what kind of public apology
i was thinking in my head i thought
what is she going to do she's going to
apologize for comments she made when she
was nine
yes that's what she's doing she is a 17
year old girl
is now being pressured by the left to
make a public apology
for comments she made when i kid you not
she was nine years old
because she made some videos where i
don't know she made fun of an
asian or a chinese accent or something
like that
like you know kids do you know how kids
do that stuff kids say silly things
and do silly things because they're kids
that's what kids it's like the
definition of kids
well she has to make this public apology
it does raise questions why would you
want
your nine-year-old kid to be on camera
on the internet that seems like a bad
idea that seems like a recipe for
disaster
just generally you don't want to expose
kids to that very young
but but beyond that
can we not have a little bit of grace
for the things that nine-year-olds say i
mean i guess what the age of reason is
seven
but let's see you know nine is still
pretty far below the age of consent i
think in
many states 17 is still below the age of
consent so can we not have a little bit
of grace for that
no of course not of course we can't not
in this culture
because no one really cares what a
nine-year-old girl
said about some chinese accent who said
no no one cares
but they want to use it as a cudgel now
to intimidate people
to whip them back in line history is
used by the left
selectively like blackmail like any
like any extortion artist like any
blackmailer like any thug
uses against his adversaries
that's that's not how history should be
used we should not approach history
as a as a tool of exploitation and we
should not exploit history
from a perspective of antagonism
we should approach history for what it
is it's things that happened in the past
that might tell us something about the
future
we should look at history as something
that is complex we should look at
history
as something that can give us a guide to
the future and if someone has for
instance a 50-year
career in politics that is highly
undignified and is increasingly radical
we should remember that too and that
should play a role in a presidential
campaign
but we must approach it in its
complexity you know you know the
craziest story is maybe is even crazier
than the maddie ziegler story
another person has been canceled
recently canceled by the university of
buffalo
it's not the president of the university
it's not a dean at the university or a
professor
it's not a conservative student it's
millard fillmore
millard fillmore the president from
1850 to 1853 is being canceled
because of the compromise of 1850 took a
long time for that one to
make its way through the the popular
culture but now
here we are 170 years later
and we're canceling millard fillmore for
the compromise of 1850 because that
included the fugitive slave act
which now the university of buffalo
recognizes that this remains a deeply
hurtful decision
especially for african americans do you
think one black guy in this entire
country
wakes up at night wailing about the
compromise of 1850
no nobody does nobody even remembers the
compromise of 1850
for goodness sakes this is not a deeply
hurtful
issue in people's present lives nobody
remembers who millard fillmore is
he's one of the most forgettable
presidents in american history and by
the way in
fillmore's defense never thought i'd
have to utter that statement
in fillmore's defense the compromise of
1850 while many would object to the
fugitive slave act staved off the civil
war for a decade
you would have had a civil war 10 years
earlier
history has complexity to it history has
nuance
but what we have to do you know in our
leftist culture
is just tear things down erase it so we
can rewrite it according
to our own preferences first they play
on forgetfulness
then the left relies on gullibility
naivete and outright stupidity i think
i think we all need to take cognitive
tests these days we're going to get to
the mailbag first though
i've got to thank you i've got to thank
all of you for heading on over
subscribing to the michael
show youtube channel i head on over
that's also where i check out the
comments
for the show so head on over there leave
some comments
also you know i've been telling you for
the past couple days about the
all-access membership tier
which is our highest tier of membership
and you get a lot of behind-the-scenes
exclusives things like that
access to chat with the hosts and the
writers so we have this very cool
product
which was a daily wire baseball bat made
here in america with the daily wire logo
emblazoned on it
it was it was in association with a
great american baseball bat company
anyway it's only available to the all
access tier and it's already sold out
it's sold out in just two days so
sorry if you didn't get yours but if you
didn't be sure to sign up for all access
right now
you will get not one but two left of
steers tumblers with your membership
and then you will be eligible for some
of these kind of more one-off
collectible type products that we're
going to be running in the future
which go apparently very quickly i
didn't even get one of these baseball
bats which i'm extremely irritated about
so head on over right now dailywire.com
knowles you'll get 20 off all access
with coupon code access that is
dailywire.com
knowles coupon code access to get 20 off
your membership
then we will be right back with the
mailbag
pour one out from millard fillmore how
about that that's 20 20 for you
as usual i'm running tight on time so
let's try to get through
as many mailbag questions as possible
from shannon dear michael of many
podcasts
both nancy pelosi and timothy mcveigh
the oklahoma city bomber
referred to federal agents as
stormtroopers is this a dog whistle i
should be wary of
or are some associations with mass
murderers
okay thanks no you shouldn't be worried
about that
because you see when
a democrat openly associates
and admires thug killers
such as fidel castro in the case of
karen bass
or shay guevara in the case of every
liberal dope walking around a college
campus with his face on their t-shirt
or in the case of using this kind of
language it doesn't matter that's
that's not only is that not a problem
but actually chekovar is a great guy
oh these mass murderers they were okay
we needed some nuance here we need some
complexity they did some good stuff once
but the minute that a conservative even
utters the
let's say they utter the phrase america
first well this is what the left will
say
america first america first you know who
else used that phrase
charles lindbergh charles lindbergh has
had sympathies that could be termed
fascistic
and was an isolationist in the world
wars ah
you're a fascist you're a nazi that's
what they'll tell you it'll it takes
like seven degrees to get to that point
but that's what they will tell you i i'm
always
amazed when the left talks about how
they're hearing all of these dog
whistles that none of the rest of us are
hearing
you know if you're hearing dog whistles
that means that you're a dog you're
that's it says a lot more about you
a lot more about the person hearing them
then about the people who are being
accused of using them from lisa what is
the difference between a cult and a
religion
but besides size and hippie clothes i'm
a catholic
and a friend asked me this and i wasn't
sure how to respond
i said it had to do with misdirected
worship but i feel like there is more to
it thanks
well it's the the term cult is used in
in different ways i mean you could you
hear
you can hear of cults even within
religions
and the word cult derives from the same
word that culture derives from
it derives from the same word that
agriculture derives from this idea of
cultivating something
within yourself and it has a
relationship obviously to worship
so we use cult in a almost exclusively
negative sense
and then religion in a positive sense
but really what we're talking about here
is true religion
and false religion and cults are false
religions
as we as we use the term today even if
you
are to say that there is such a thing as
true religion and false religion you
you will be ostracized from polite
liberal society because we're all
supposed to pretend
that all religions are exactly the same
and you know man it's like we're all
just grabbing different parts of the
elephant man
and one guy grabs the leg and he thinks
that it's
a tree you know and one guy grabs the
the trunk and he thinks it's a fire hose
you know and one guy
but really man we're all grabbing the
same religion you know
man this is really helping my
coronavirus thanks nancy pelosi and
that just isn't the case religions make
claims
and those claims are true or they're
false and those claims cannot
be true and false at the same time so to
give an example
christianity says that christ is the
second person of the blessed trinity
the incarnate son of god who is who from
the very beginning was with god
and was god and is god right because he
is alive and he's resurrected from the
dead
literally and then ascends into heaven
those are all claims
those are either true or false islam
which
it can be viewed historically as a
christian heresy
that splits off after muhammad
encountered a
heretical christian monk named bahira
and developed
a system of christian heresy that denies
the divinity of christ
and denies the resurrection for them or
denies the crucifixion even
that makes different claims and
those can't simultaneously be true
there's nothing offensive
about saying that some things are true
and some things are false we do this in
politics all the time
right we say this this is true and this
is false
we do this as matters of history all the
time we do this
as matters of philosophy all the time i
guess the way that we do it in our
modern culture
is we talk about science because science
has now taken on
this sort of idolized
status and so we say science is precise
but everything else is not precise
science is right or wrong true or false
but everything else it's just your
opinion man
well opinions are statements of fact as
we see it and those statements in fact
are true or false
so i think the real difference we're
talking about here is true religion and
false religion and
i would recommend pursuing true religion
from jeremy howdy mostly peaceful
podcaster knowles reclaiming my time
i have a terrible problem that i must
get your advice on it's about cigars
so you know this a very serious
situation they give me migraines michael
migraines on the level of which only a
mouse with very sensitive hearing
trapped in aoc's apartment would
understand reclaiming my time
what is a brand that may not hurt this
strong man with weak sinus cavities
p.s you may now go to the bathroom wow
that wasn't amazing
i felt like i was actually back in that
democratic
congressional hearing just the way that
all that was really really beautifully
done
i'm sorry that cigars give you migraines
uh you got to toughen up pal
i'm sorry to tell you that i'm someone
who you know has
sinus issues as well but
you just i think maybe you're smoking
them wrong i get i get migraines all the
time
but something that might happen is you
you could get a little bit sick you know
maybe a headache
if you smoke on an empty stomach or if
you're smoking cigars that are a little
too full-bodied or too strong
you know for where you are right now so
i would start off with something a
little bit lighter
also you could get cigar get migraines
and headaches
if you're smoking low quality cigars so
you should just smoke higher quality
service even if they're stronger you
they'll they'll go easier on you
um some some cigars are a little harsh
in particular
um dominican tobacco can be kind of
harsh
cuban tobacco is not harsh at all it's
really soft and smooth connecticut shade
tobacco is a little bit lighter too so
you might try connecticut wrappers
in terms of lower kind of lower shelf
but very high quality cigars
cusano 18 nub kane
uh oliva all make connecticut varietals
and that connecticut shade wrapper i
think will maybe help you out i love
connecticut shade tobacco
from michael hey michael i'm trying to
learn more about our country's history
and was wondering if you had any
recommendations
i'm currently reading the federalist but
i don't know what to jump to next thanks
so much
well the federalist is just a tremendous
place to start
and and we'll tell you a lot about our
constitutional system
i would recommend reading some of these
popular history books i've recommended
them on the show before
david mccullough 1776 and nathaniel
philbrick's mayflower
i think those two books are they're
really readable they read like novels
but they
really give you a sense a wonderful
sense of the that founding era
you can also check out ron chernow's
washington and hamilton biographies
those are good
too obviously more more tailored to
those individual men but
1776 tells you a lot about the american
revolution a wonderful way
and the mayflower tells you about the
first founding of america back
back with the pilgrims at plymouth rock
all right
from jared dear michael in episode 591
you asked if anyone in the world thinks
new york city doesn't think the black
lives matter
i personally don't think new york city
cares about black lives nor does their
incompetent mayor
because if they did care about black
lives they'd be sending officers to save
black lives from shootings
rather than sending them to protect
marxist murals on the streets would you
agree
yeah i think that's true you know they
i would say these leftist politicians
care about black lives
in the way that bad mothers care about
their children
in that you know good mothers care about
their children
bad mothers care about their own
fantasy of their children you see the
difference
they care about their children in as
much as it
serves their own preferences about their
children what they want their children
to want
how they want their children to be how
they imagine that their children are not
the real person
just this kind of fantasy in in the
mother's mind and we all we we've all
met mothers who who are like this to
their children
that's the same way the leftist
politicians or we talked about this
earlier
on in the show
four out of five black people in america
want more police funding or at least the
same
amount of police funding in their
neighborhoods blm doesn't care about
that and the leftist
politicians even some republican ones
who are who are bending the knee to blm
don't care about that either there's a
big gap between what the people want
and what the ideologues want the people
to want
and you know unfortunately if you're if
all you care about is this
fantasy of the other person in your mind
then then you don't really love them at
all you're not you don't really will
the good of the other you will the good
of this this imaginary
contrivance in your own head that's it
we run out of time
as always we have more questions to get
to we'll have to wait until next week
in the meantime i'm michael knowles the
michael knowles show see you then
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies
executive producer jeremy bourie
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
technical producer austin stevens
assistant director
pavel wadowski editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer robin
fenderson
hair and makeup nika geneva production
assistant
ryan love the michael knowles show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire
2020. you know the matte wall show it's
not just another show about
about politics i think there are enough
of those already out there we talk about
culture because culture drives politics
and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are life
family faith those are fundamental and
that's what this show
is about hope you'll give it a listen